we're launching a new series called
rebuilding america to showcase the
ingenuity of individuals and communities
who are working together to build a
better world one project at a time this
morning we head to new mexico to the
biggest cluster of out-of-this-world
homes known as earthships they're at the
forefront of sustainable housing and
built from things you might find in a
junkyard janet chamblin shows us how
concerns about climate change and energy
prices are driving a huge increase in
their popularity
along a rural road in northern new
mexico they rise from the dusty desert
with futuristic shapes resembling
something from another planet but these
are what's known as earth ships off the
grid homes built into the ground made
mostly from recycled materials what some
would call garbage
like used tires tightly packed with dirt
for insulation and structural walls
and old bottles that become part of the
interior it's kind of like stained glass
but we're using all recycled bottles
there are no power lines water lines or
sewage lines connected to this earth
ship under construction
electricity is generated from solar
panels water is collected on the roof
then filtered and the treated sewage
nourishes plants and trees this is the
outer greenhouse 76 year old architect
michael reynolds is the grandfather of
the earthship concept so this is kind of
the inner part of the building building
the first one in 1979 and teaching
others ever since
there are more than 100 earth ships here
potentially many more soon are you able
to quantify the increase in you know
inquiries that you're getting well i
would say it's doubled
in the last couple years uh no in in the
last couple of months
skyrocketing energy prices and a growing
desire to live sustainably amid climate
change are fueling demand for homes that
generally don't use fuel what's it like
to live in an earthship
uh
it was a very very small leap the what
you're told at the beginning oh my
goodness you're off grid that's got to
be the worst thing in the world john
lasalla spent 40 years living and
working in new york city i love the way
this house functions he bought this air
ship five years ago for about 300
thousand dollars and says he hasn't
looked back you practice what we all
should be practicing which is
conservation so if there's clouds for
three days you don't turn on the
inverter which means you have
electricity for the primary stuff but
your computer and your stereo can't plug
in this room
was uh built by the original owners his
1200 square foot home has no microwave
and no clothing dryer on the other hand
the propane to heat water cost him about
90 dollars a year
no regrets no none at all not at all i
wouldn't live any other way
a way others are considering we have a
few things going on today to finish the
house this is the earthship academy
a four-week immersive class where people
from all over travel to the community
about a 30-minute drive from taos
learning like this hollywood production
designer bianca faro how to build an
earthship every job we build all our
sets and then we throw everything in the
trash and so i've just found over the
years that in my free time
i just want to combat that in some way i
want to find solutions this home is
already sold to a florida couple
the students live in an earthship while
they learn you just have to come and see
and experience it i've been living in
one for almost a month you don't need a
class to check out life off the grid so
this is just a master bedroom with a
walk-in closet down below homes like
this are available on vacation rental
sites it's a chance to test drive a
lifestyle of extreme sustainability
just don't bring a hair dryer what would
you say to someone who's looking around
and interested in
potentially living this way your typical
human still
lives for the american dream my custom
home with my dressing room that has room
for 60 pairs of shoes and blah blah blah
blah blah those days in my mind i'm
already seeing it
are gone earth ships are an oddity
but amid renewed interest in living
untethered a surge of eco-friendly
construction here
and for those who've already made the
lifestyle choice validation it's kind of
like a conspiracy of enlightenment you
know everybody's their way but they live
here all for basically the same reason
they want to be off grid they like the
isolation of it they like the stunning
beauty of it and they think this is a
better way to go other worldly homes
designed to protect earth for cbs
morning's janet chamleon at the
earthship community in new mexico
i am fascinated by this yeah yeah it's
very cool looking but i would like some
neighbors
i don't want to live out there i live in
new mexico that's where this was yeah
and i like new mexico but i would just
like some neighbors but i do think it's
very cool i like what he said a
conspiracy of enlightenment and that you
could test drive the lifestyle if you
want to to see if it's for you but the
house looks nice yeah i don't want to
generalize people in america but i'll
describe myself i do live in excess and
i realize that you know you walk around
your house you have more than you need
lights on everywhere yeah and you're
wasting energy and i think to myself as
i am an aspiring minimalist how can i
downsize my life in a way that is more
fulfilling but then also better for the
world and this right here is an
opportunity so are you ready to test
drive i'm going to test it out i'm going
to rent it i'm going to listen one of my
next vacations i'll rent it okay sure
i'll let you all right we're coming
right rebuilding america is sponsored by
steel find yours at steeleusa.com